الناس عرفت كده
بس خلي الناس خرجت خلاص
احنا كده على الهوا
اوكي
احنا يعني مساء الخير مره تانيه احنا
اسفين
زي الاسبوع اللي فات او من اسبوعين كده
حدث برضو انقطاع
ولكن
هنا كمان لكن عدنا مره اليكم مره تانيه
انا اسف جدا حاجه خارج ارادتنا انما اهو
رجعنا تاني مره معكم اذا كان في اسئله
اخرى نكمل مع حضراتكم ما كانش اوجه لكم
الشكر احنا فين طيب رجعت الاخوه مره تانيه
هل وقف
منور مره تانيه ربنا يخليك انا هنا صفاء
اهلا وسهلا يا صفاء
[موسيقى]
موجودين اهلا وسهلا
سلام عليكم استاذنا الكبير ربنا يخليك
العوده للطرح الثقافي التاريخي ومراجعه
الكتب في القناه قدر الاستطاعه حاضر والله
مساء الخير والسعاده استاذ سيد ربنا يسعدك
يا اسلام هل ممكن ان تدخل اتمنى منك استاذ
سيد هل من الممكن ان تدخل امريكا ضد الدعم
السريع كما فعلت مع جيش الرب الاوغندي من
قبل والله اشك ان امريكا تعمل اي حاجه
اكتر حاجه ان هي تطلب من حلفائها انه
وبعدين الصدام السريع يعني على علاقه
كويسه بالولايات المتحده يعني
لكن هي تدخل بمعنى يعني
زي ايام الحرب البارده كده العمليه صعبه
يعني
ما اعتقدش ان عندها سبب ارتفاع لذلك
مساء الخير ايه تاثير اللي بيحصل على
مشكله سد النهضه تاثير سيء جدا لانه
مصر داخله في صراع مع اثيوبيا الصراع ده
كان من مصلحه مصر ان يكون في سلطه مستقره
في السودان
[موسيقى]
بتنحس فيه الى مصر في حاله وجود هذه
الفوضى وانشغال السودان بمشاكله الداخليه
ده يقوي الموقف الاثيوبي طبعا
تمام رجع البث ربنا يخليك يا فارس الوضع
هيكون عامل ازاي الفتره اللي جايه من حيث
التضخم التضخم حازم
طبعا الارقام الرسميه بتصدر يعني من جهات
الاحصاء لكن الواضح المؤشرات بتقول انه
التضخم ما فيش مؤشرات على تراجعه في
الفتره المقبله اللي هي على الشهور
المقبله لانه اسباب الازمه ما زالت قائمه
ما شاء الله ده عدد الاسئله
مسا مسا ده محمد محمد
ماشي يا محمد مسا مسا
رايك في احداث فلسطين الاخيره ايه فلسطين
احداث الاخيره يا عبد الله لو بتتكلم على
ايه بقى بتتكلم على يعني
يعني
امبارح اول امبارح ولا بتتكلم في الفتره
الاخيره واعتداء
المستوطنين على الفلسطينيين ويعني يا ريت
تحدد يعني لماذا ايران نجحت في صنع دوله
قويه
نسبيا وهي دوله دينيه هل ذلك بسبب
ثقافاتهم
ثقافات مذهبهم انا مش خبير في حكايه
المذاهب يعني وتاثير الثقافه الشيعيه
والسنيه ولكن
عندها مجموعه من الاعتبارات اولا هم شعب
السبب الرئيسي يعني غير ان هم كان عندهم
قاعده من زمان وقاعده صناعيه والكلام ده
كله بس مش هو ده السبب رئيس الحقيقه السبب
الرئيسي انه
الايرانيين واجهوا ضغوط عنيفه جدا جدا بعد
الثوره الاسلاميه
خليتهم خل ظهرهم للحيط وبالتالي كان لابد
بما انه ما فيش من يمد يد العون فعلا ليهم
كان عليهم ان هم
ومنعت منهم تكنولوجيا من دول مختلفه شرقا
وغربا بشكل جاد كان عليهم ان هم عشان
يواجهوا هذا العالم المتوحش يعني ان هم
يطوروا تكنولوجيا السلاح ان يطوروا
التكنولوجيا النوويه انه
يعتمدوا بانفسهم خصوصا انه مع حرب العراق
واعتقادهم ان العالم كله ضدهم وجزء من
كلامهم ما كانش غلط يعني
بداوا يعتمدوا على ثقافه الاعتماد على
النفس يعني فده كان السبب اللي اخذهم الى
هذا المستوى المتقدم نسبيا زي ما انت قلت
بدقه يعني حامد الصخري ما مصير الدول
المطبعه مع سوريا من العقوبات الاقتصاديه
الامريكيه هو ده السؤال اللي هيفرض نفسه
انه الدول بعد اذا الدول دي طبعت وبدات
لان احنا لسه يعني الكلام مش رسمي يعني
انما طبعا السعوديه رايحه الامارات راحت
دول كتيره رايحه لكن لاحظ انه العقوبات
الامريكيه ليست مع التطبيع يعني العقوبات
الامريكيه لا تطال من يطبع لكن تطال من
يستثمر المفروض الدول العربيه بتفكر ان
الخطوه الثانيه بعد عمليه اعاده العلاقات
ان هي تضغط على الولايات المتحده تطلب من
الولايات المتحده انه ايه هي مطالبكم من
سوريا نتفاهم عليها في مقابل ان انتم
ترفعوا العقوبات اللي ممكن تمنعنا من
الاستثمار في سوريا
طبعا اذا وافق الاسد على كل الشروط دول
الخليج
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد معك احمد عندي
سؤال هل يوجد علاقه بين الاحتباس الحراري
وماندو ليه كده يا اخواننا يعني ايه علاقه
الاحتباس الحراريه
[ضحك]
ماشي اتمنى منك استاذ سيد العوده للطرح
انا انا اقرا السؤال الاول وبعدين اعرفه
على فكره فيعني رجاء ده ماشي ده مزاح كتر
خيركم يعني اوكي بس يعني في حاجات ممكن
تسبب حرج فانا اقرب تلقائيه فبلاش تحطوا
حاجات ممكن تعمل لي حركه يعني اتمنى منك
يا استاذ سيد العوده للطرح الثقافي
لا يمل من السماع اليك استاذ سيد ربنا
يخليك بس انا اسف مش عارفه اقرا اسم حضرتك
شكرا مساء الخير خالد احمد هل هناك وزن
سياسي لخروج البشير من السجن
خروج
يعني اقطاب رموز النظام البشير طبعا هيكون
مؤثر مش بس مؤثر لانه هم
كان عندهم انصرهم وعندهم شبكاتهم الماليه
وعندهم جامعات بتدعمهم ولكن لانه
الرئيس عمر حسن البشير اصبح قميص عثمان
الجيش بيقول
الدعم السريع هو اللي
فتح لهم السجون عشان يعمل فوضى والدعم
السريع بيقول الجيش هو اللي سمح بدعمهم
لانه هو محكوم منهم فطبعا ده هيربك المشهد
اكثر مما هو مرتبك انت مش بتطرع ناس عليها
يا قضايا شيكات
غارمين وكلام انت بتتكلم على سياسيين
حكموا السودان لتلاتين سنه طبعا ياثر
لماذا هل هناك لماذا لا يريد النظام
السوري عوده
اللاجئين للسوريا
صفاء يا صفاء ما هو قال قبل كده الرئيس
السوري قال والله الازمه ديت من كان من
مزاياها ان هي خلصت سوريا من عدم الانسجام
الذي كانت تعيش فيه وتحدث عن سوريا
المفيده وبغض النظر عن احاديثه اللي تحتمل
التاويل ممكن يقول ما كانش قصده كده يعني
الحسبه كده في سوريا انه في ناس حسبته مش
ده رايي انه ناس تركونا
اما لانهم فضلوا الامان وان يعيشوا حياه
رغده وسوريا بيتم التامر عليها من العالم
وهربوا من التجنيد وهربوا من كذا وكذا
الكلام ده طبعا يعني انا لا اتفق معاه
لانه المواطن ما يقدرش يخاطر بحياته يعني
في حرب ان ربما لم يفرضها ولم يطلبها لكن
يعني ده منطق بعض المسؤولين السوريين خلاص
عاوزين يرجعوا يرجعوا بشروطنا يعني
وفي ناس احله ان هم ياخدوا بيوتهم الى
اخره وبالتالي هو مش عاوز عوده اللاجئين
ليه بيقول لك انا عندي اولويات اولويه رقم
واحد اسيطر الاول على الاراضي اولويه رقم
اثنين اقدر
ابتدي ادير الملفات قبول المجتمع الدوليه
واعمل عمليه الاعمار في المناطق الحرجه
التكلفه تكون قليله لو جالي اللاجئين عاوز
تكلفه ضخمه وعاوز عمليه اعمار بكامل
السودان يعني دخول اطراف دوليه من كل طرف
من كل حدب ودخولهم لن يكون مجانا يكون
بشروط هو مش عاوز شروط وعاوز عمليه اعاده
اعمار محدوده يبدا بها
في المناطق اللي يقدر يصلحها باقل قدر
ممكن من المساعدات الخارجيه اي باقل قدر
من الشروط وبعدين لكل حادث حديث ضعف سوري
على رجليها خلال خمس سنين عشر سنين ويصبح
اللاجئين مطلب من الدول مش وسيله ضغط من
فضله خدهم وندفع لك مساعدات مش انا اديهم
لي وارجعهم لي وانا اجري انا ورايا
المساعدات وعاوز يعمل العكس يخلي الدول هي
اللي تتحايل عليه
ترجع لنا نرجع لك اللاجئين في مقابل ان
احنا بكذا وكذا وكذا
حميت السبب ماشي يا محمد مبارك
ده وجهه نظر ناس كتيره بتقول كده يا اخونا
ما تاثير السد الضخم الذي تبنيه جنوب
السودان وهل بموافقه مصر ما اعرفش ان في
سد كبير غير السد اللي انا اعرفه من عده
سنوات ولم يكن مؤثرا في شيء على مصريين ده
اذا كانت ما فيش سد التاني بيتكلموا عليه
ولو اعتقد لو كان فيكم هسمع يعني ماذا
يمكن ان تقدم مصر لحل تلك المشكله بتتكلم
على السودان
الشان السوداني
عاوز تدفر جهود كتيره عاوز مصر وعاوز
الخليج وعاوز الثلاثيه والرباعيه والعالم
كله يعني مصر تقدر تقدم طبعا يعني تقدر ان
هي تمون على بعض الاطراف تقدر تلعب دور
وسيط يعني تقدر تقدر تضغط على بعض الاطراف
واذا مصر ما لعبتش دور في حل المشكله
السودانيه هتمارس النفوس ده فين يعني دي
مشكله بالغه الحيويه لمصر ما هو مصير
مرتزقه انقره في الشمال الغربي السوري
مدى جزء من يعني بغض النظر انت هتسميهم
مرتزقه وانا هقول يعني حلفاء لانه انا مش
عاوز اكون طرف في التوصيف يعني ولكن ما هو
انت لما تيجي تعمل قضايا الحل النهائي بقى
هتلاقي فيه قضايا كثيره عالقه ما مصير
الكرد ما مصير الناس اللي موجودين في ادلب
ما مصير ما يسمى بالجيش السوري الحر لازم
هتكون في عند المفاوضات
انه يتم استيعاب هؤلاء
تصنيفهم كاتيجاريس يعني هتكون ده من
القضايا الشائكه بقى عند التفاوض مع
الاتراك والتفاوض مع الخليجين كل فصيل كان
عنده دوله بتدعمه لازم تدافع عنه عشان
تحتفظ بولائه ليه حين الحاجه له في
المستقبل
انا استاذنكم احنا عندنا اسئله كثيره
مساء الخير استاذ سيد هل يا ترى ان
الاغلبيه في السودان لاحد الطرفين
اغلبيه ايه ده هو ما فيش انتخابات يا
صديقنا تقصد ان الغلبه بقى المساله مساله
قوه نظريا على الورق الغلبه
السوداني بس مش عارف القوه بتاعه الجيش
السوداني هتساعده في ايه اذا كان بيحارب
في المدن هل هيستخدم الاسلحه الثقيله في
مسح الخرطوم مثلا لا قدر الله
انا مش شايف انه يعني عمليه معقده على
فعلا الكسر فيها خسران يعني
ما تاثير الصد اجاب ناس السيد سؤال بسيط
هل مصر تقدم دعما من اي نوع للجيش
السوداني لا اعلم انها تقدم دعم للجيش
السوداني ولكن اعلم انها في صف الجيش
السوداني اذا ساءت الامور لا استبعد ان
تقدم دعما للكاش السوداني
واعتقد ان مصر وقتها هتقول يعني انا ما
بعملش حاجه مخجله ده الجيش السوداني اللي
هو بيمثل الدوله السودانيه
قوات الدعم
فصيل منشق عليه وطبعا الفصيل المعارض او
الدول المعارضه يقولوا الدعم قوات الدعم
دي قوات شرعيه
ونظمها القانون والبرلمان السوداني وهيظل
طبعا لا قدر الله اذا طال الصراع فرصه
للكل انه يتدخل لكن بتقول لي استبعد لا
استبعد
مستقبل السيسي ما هو يعني ايه مستقبل
السيسي ما هو اخونا احمد وهو السيسي هو
الرئيس الحالي عنده انتخابات 2024
هيدخل الانتخابات كما هو متوقع لا اعتقد
ان هيكون هناك من ينافسه ابدا لان
المنافسه دي ما بتتولدش قبل الانتخابات
بشهر في الغالب ما لم يكن بقى في معجزات
جايه هي فوز في الانتخابات الموجوده وسوف
يظل في السلطه الى ان يشاء الله
عبد الله استاذ سيد سؤال بسيط هل مصر تقدم
دعم اجابه السؤال اجابته يا عبد الله هل
تتوقع حرب طويله الامد في السودان
لا اتوقع حربا قصيره في السودان
لكن فرص التسويه مش معدومه لانه الاخطار
كبيره جدا على كل طرف مدرك انه صعب انه
يتحرك صعب انه يحسم الصراع وصعب انه يكمل
الحرب في المدن بهذا الشكل وبالتالي لا
استبعد انه بعد فتره يتم اجبار كل الاطراف
على الجلوس ولكن الدول اللي عاوزه تقوم
بطور الوسيط بتشوف في الاول في حد ممكن
يحسم الصراع ويريحنا ولا لا يعني
هل صعود او نزول الذهب في السوق العالميه
له علاقه بما يحدث في السودان
والله دي عاوزه حد يكون خبير في شؤون
الذهب بس انا مش متخيل يعني انه خلال
اسبوعين يحصل شح في الانتاج في دوله واحده
يؤدي الى
ان السوق كله يرتبك هو مش زي سوء النفط
لكن انا بفتي كده يعني انا بستبعد لكن انا
الحقيقه لست
مؤهلا للاجابه على هذا السؤال الفني اللي
عاوز واحد متخصص في سوق الذهب
بس في سبب تاني خلاني اغراني بالاجابه على
طول ان انا معلوماتي ان كتير من سوق الذهب
كان بيتم خارج السلطه يعني واللي كان
بينتجه هو قوات الدعم السريع والفريق
حميتي مش متخيل ان هي عطلت امس يعني لكن
لا ادري الاجابه افضل ان انا
اختصر اجابه واقول لا اعلم
هل فعلا الغرب يسعى لابقاء الصراع في
الدول العربيه مشتعلا حيث اشعلها في
السودان بعد ان بعد انتفائها في اليمن
والسوريه لم تنطفئ في اليمن ولم تنطفئ في
سوريا هي خفت جدوتها فقط هل الغرب يسعى
للابقاء على الصرع انا يعني حقيقه اخونا
عزيز انا بعتقد انه النوع ده من التعميمات
يعني انا ما بتفقش معه الغرب مش كتله
واحده ومش دائما مصالحه في اشعال الصراع
النظريه التقليديه ان انا كلما اضعفت
الدول قدرت اتسيد الدول العربيه ضعيفه
بالفعل فعل يعني هتضعف سوري اكثر ما هي
كده هي تضعف اليمن اكتر ما هي كده ايه
احيانا ضعفها وتشضيه اكثر من اللازم ممكن
يسبب لهم ضرر
هل تتوقع الصراع يتمدد الى دول عربيه اخرى
اتوقع يا سعد ان يمتد الى دول اخرى مش
لازم دول عربيه قد يمتد الى تشاد قد يمتد
الى جنوب السودان قد يمتد الى اثيوبيا
ده هو اللي ممكن قد يمتد الى اريتريا
ده اللي انا اتوقعه يعني ده الاقرب للمنطق
لا قدر له اذا طال الصراع كيف ترى حركه
الافروسانتريك وما هو سر الترويج لذوي
البشره السمراء في الفتره الاخيره مصطفى
هو انا مش عارف ابني الاجابه على السؤال
على انه كله عارف الافرسان ولا لا بس
الافرو سانتريك ما حركه جديده قوي بس يعني
هي موجوده من مثلا بتاع التلاتين سنه ولا
40 سنه ولا حاجه كانت فكرتها
انه بعض الاساتذه والمؤرخين السود بيقولوا
والله احنا مهمشين في الحضاره البيضاء
وبنتعامل على ان احنا ناس اي كلام يعني
فاحنا لو ركزنا على ما يرونه حقيقه
التاريخ واظهرناه بدات في امريكا امتدادا
للحركات القوميه السوداء في دول اخرى زي
اثيوبيا مثلا العظمه الاثيوبيه نائم تلات
برضو على اننا الاثيوبي الاسود المتفوق
لكنها يعني تركزت في في امريكا
وخدت الاسم ده اخره يعني التركيز على
العرق الافريقي ده يخلينا نشعر بالزهو
وبالتالي نخلينا منحسش به ان احنا او اقل
وبالتالي ده يعزز قدرتنا على الانجاز في
مجتمع بينظر لنا على اننا يعني اقل
وفكرتهم بدات لازم نرجع للماضي نقرا
التاريخ صعب التاريخ صعب بمعنى ايه انه في
حضارات افريقيه كثيره لم يتم التركيز
عليها والحضاره اللي تم التركيز عليها لا
الحضاره المصريه
سرقت بمعنى ان الحضاره المصريه كانت حضاره
سوداء
وبما انه اذا هم اثبتوا هذه العلاقه يبقى
الحضاره المصريه اللي هي اعظم من اي حضاره
قديمه بيضاء زي حضاره الاغريق او روما
يبقى الرجل الاسود ده راجل عبقري وانه
مشكلته انه سرقت منه هذه الحضاره من الرجل
الابيض اللي انتصر اللي سرق الحضاره
المصريه
وسرق علمائها وانتشر العلماء المصريين
السود في كل دول العالم
يعني ساهموا بشكل وافر في الحضاره عندما
ببساطه كده
سر التركيز عليها انه مع
الصعود او مع الانقسام الامريكي وموجود
حركه بتشعر انه الصوت ما زالوا في امريكا
مضطهدين فاكيد حركه الافرسان
لازم تنتعش بس الحقيقه انا عندي تفسير
ابسط من كده لان انا كنت بسال بالصدفه
امبارح بس بنتي يعني حد من ولادي بيقول لي
انه انا بسالهم انتم ليه عارفين كلكم
الافرسان انا كنت قاعد مع مجموعه من
الشباب ولادي وحد في العيله لقيت الشباب
كلهم في العشرات كله
فسالتهم انتم بتعرفوا كلكم القصه دي منين
يعني انتم ما عندكمش يعني
ايوه كده بالظبط وبعدين قالوا لي على كيفن
هارت
كليوباترا
ده احيا ثاني موضوع الاف عشان كده برده
الناس بتسال على الموضوع
يعني اذا كنتوا سمعتوا منذ فكده ده صحيح
برضه فيلم كليوباترا اللي ان شاء الله
ممكن نعمل حاجه لو كان والله قوي حاضر
انما انا فوجئت ان الشباب يعرفوا ان في
بعض المشاهير السود زي كيفن هارت اظن
ومراته ومرات ويل سميث مهتمين بالقصه ديت
فابتدى هم قريبين للنجوم ديت وبالتالي
ابتدوا يعرفوها يعني
السيد هل ابقاء الوضع بدون
تفوق طرف يعني
ما شاء الله الاسئله كتيره جدا
طيب احاول ان انا
بس المره دي بقى في الحلقه التانيه مش
اصدقاءك بقى ناس كثيره بعد ما تحرروا من
اصدقائك اللي انت
لماذا
كيف ترى حركه الافرسان وما هو سر الطريق
لاجابنا
فداء لماذا تصر فرنسا على انتخاب رئيس في
لبنان تابع لحزب الله مع العلم ان الغرب
وامريكا قاموا بحصار الاقتصاد اللبناني
وخلق الازمه الاقتصاديه فما هذا التناقض
في السياسه
انا ما اعرفش المعلومه اللي انت بتقول انه
فرنسا عاوزه حد من حزب الله دي ممكن تكون
في معنديش المعلومه انما سواء كانوا
عاوزين اولائهم فشلوا يعني لو كانت فرنسا
بتفكر كده
فهي تفكيرها يعني مش مش حاجه شاذه قوي لان
هم مدركين القوى الكبرى اذا كان الفرنسيين
او غيرهم يعني انا ما اعرفش المعلومه
بيقولوا لازم يكون في توافق على الرئيس من
اكبر قوه في لبنان اللي هي حزب الله
والكلام منطقي لانه اذا حزب الله اعترض
الرئيس هيعمل ايه ماشي الحركه ازاي
الحقيقه هتقف
معنى هذا انه
معنى ذلك ان اللاجئين سيعيشون في مصر صفاء
وفي لاجئين كتير عايشين في مصر في سوريين
وفي يمنيين وفي ليبيين مئات الالاف
والسوريين بالملايين السعوديه تقود
محاولات الهدوء في المنطقه لاجل تطور
دولنا وازدهارها بعد ذلك
اشتعل الصرع في السودان هل تعتقد انه صراع
طبيعي او مفتعل لا يعني مش شايف ان هو
مفتعل ولا حاجه لانه كان انت بتتكلم على
انه حكايه انه السعوديه بتقود عمليه
التهدئه الكلام ده بدا في 2021
وبدا بالتدريج وبطيء ووصل ذروته دلوقتي
انما قبل توجه السعوديه او قبل توجه
الامارات وقبل توجه تركيا كان الصراع
بيشتعل منذ سقوط البشير فالمساله كانت
موجوده وبصراحه مش الغريب ان هي اشتعلت
الغريبه ان هي ما اشتعلتش قبل دلوقتي
هل ابقاء ده اخونا
هل ابقاء الوضع بدون تفوق طرف يعني انقسام
السودان
وليشكل ذلك خطرا على الامن المائي لمصر
وان كان القسم الجنوبي وسرد من اثيوبيا
مساند من اثيوبيا شوف يا صادقنا الجزء
اللي يخص هل ده يؤدي الى انقسام السودان
وتفتتها طبعا اذا كبر الصراع ممكن يؤدي
طبعا لتفتت السودان
ايه الحافز للاطراف ان هي يعني تبقى
منضبطه مع المركز اذا كان المركز لا
يستطيع ان يقدم الخدمات الاساسيه لها يعني
يمثل خطر على الامن المائي لمصر طبعا يمثل
خطر على الامن المائي لمصر
اسئله عجبناها
هل الحرب العالميه الثالثه قريبه اقصد
اصطدام العسكري المباشر
يعني الاجابه لا مش قريبه يعني طبعا لكن
يعني هو الكلام الاقرب انه الكلام عن
الحرب العالميه ما بقاش مبقاش خيال علمي
يعني
لماذا مصر خادع للامارات في الملف
السوداني رغم خطوره الوضع على مصر ازاي
خاضعه عليها مصر بتدعم بشكل واضح الجيش
السوداني فيما انه الامارات
اقرب الى الفريق حمدي يعني مش شايف ان انا
شايف ان هم دولتين حليفتين عندهم اولويات
مختلفه في ملفات مختلفه وده مش امر غريب
ولا حاجه
استاذنا هل ترى علاقه بما يحدث في السودان
والملء الرابع لسد السد في اثيوبيا لا لا
ارى يا اخونا علي كيف ترى حركه اجت على
افروسان اسرائيل في السودان في ظل الوضع
الحالي انا اعتقد ان اسرائيل ممكن تكون
متضرره لان هي كان من مصلحتها انه يحصل
عمليه استقرار مش ازدهار يعني استقرار في
السودان في ظل انه الجيش عاوز يطبع والدعم
السريع عاوز يطبع بالعكس ده كانت فيه خطوه
عاوزين يبنوا عليها انت النظريه بقى ان
اسرائيل عاوزه تهد الاطراف والكلام ده كله
لما تكون السودان دوله قويه ومناوئه مثلا
كما يعني في دول
لها لكن السودان بيعاني من مشاكل من سنوات
طويل ولم يعد مناوئا لاسرائيل
هل سيتم تحرير السوق
وخصخصه شركات الجيش بشكل اكبر كما وصي
صندوق النقد
والله المفروض ان الحكومه متفقه على هذا
يا مهاب بتتكلم على مصر اكيد ايوه هم
متفقين على كده لكن المساله ماشيه بطيء
لاسباب يعني مفهومه بالنسبه لي على الاقل
بس انت ما سالتنيش عليها ولو اتكلمنا عنها
هناخد يومين شيماء المشكله في امريكا التي
تشعل نار الحروب لعدم
مرور طريق الحرير واستنزاف الروس
مش عارف يا شيماء
مش عارف هل هي فعلا ليها علاقه باللي
بيحصل بكده ولا لا يعني انا مش شايفه ومش
شايف ان هي شايفه يعني يعني مش حتى
السودان كتير في اولوياتها يعني استاذ هل
في صعود او اجبنا كيف اجبنا لماذا لا تعيد
مصر والمغرب علاقه هنا مع ايران والله
السؤال ده انا بس لا انا عارف ليه ايران
بس مش عارف مش عارف ليه المغرب بس مش عارف
ليه مصر
المغرب احنا عندنا كم دوله ما عندهاش
علاقات عندنا مصر
وعندنا
البحرين وعندنا المغرب كل دوله من دول
مفهومه اللي هي فيما يتعلق بالمغرب مثلا
البحرين بدات خطوات وطبعا كان عندها مشاكل
مع يعني حريم مفهوم موقفها بس انت ما
سالتني يعني على موضوع ما سالتنيش عليه
المغرب قالت ان انا عشان ارجع علاقتي
بايران
بل كمان التطبيع مع سوريا لازم الاثنين لا
يعترف بحركه البوليساريو ويتوقف عن دعمها
لان هي قطعت العلاقات بسبب هذه المشكله
يعني
انما مصر انا بقى قلت لك موقف مصر الخارجي
من ايران وسوريا انا بصراحه مش فاهمه
يعني كان في فتره كانت المصريين بيقولوا
والله
طبعا في فتره كانت مصر على اتصالات مع
ايران وكان في فتره كانوا هترجع العلاقات
او تتحسن مره تتعثر من ايران ومره تتعثر
من مصر بس انا مش قادر اتخيل ان المساله
متعثره من ايران اللي انفتحت على السعوديه
وانفتحت على دول الخليج
ومش قادر اتخيل ليه متعثره بين مصر اذا
كان السبب مصر ما دام حتى الاعتبار الخليج
اللي كانت مصر بتراعيه لم يعد قائما يعني
امتى السيسي يبطل
تبذير فلوس والشعب العشوائيات بدون تعليم
وبدون خدمات
ده مش رايه هو يعني انت بتقول يعني
وجهه نظره انه احنا لما نصلح العشوه اياد
ده حق اصيل للناس انه احنا شغالين في
التعليم وانفقنا مليارات على التعليم ده
مش وجهه نظره انما هو لو انت عاوز تقول
ليه في بعض المشروعات القوميه اللي هي محل
شك او مش محل اجماع ده صحيح بس حتى
المشروعات ديت فيها اخده جد هل هي اولويه
ولا لا يعني يعني انت لو طرحت عليه السؤال
ده لو انت رحت في مؤتمر او قابلت مسؤول
وبتاع هتلاقي ان المساله مش ابيض واسود
يعني
هم عندهم التصور التصور ده ما ثبتش انه
عبقري انما عندهم تصور
يعني مش هيستسلم تماما لوجهه نظرك يقول لك
ايوه احنا هنا في انفاق سفير ولا بتاع
يقول لك لا ده عشان كذا وده علشان كذا
تحيا تحيه لاستاذنا سيد الجبيل مع رايك
فيما يحصل في حدود النيجر الشمالي لا اعلم
يا صديقي انا اسف مش عارف كيف ترى حركه
الافرسانتريك يا مصطفى انت كنت قلقان انا
طرحت كتير قوي ههه
انا اسف استاذنكم واقفه على الساعه عشره
امتى اجابنا امتى هل هناك ايوه ايوه ده
مصطفى وخالد سيطره خالص
عزيز هل فعلا الغرب يسعى لابقاء الصراع في
الدول العربيه لا اجبناه
انا استاذنكم اعتقد ان احنا فاضل لنا ثلاث
دقائق هل في سؤال مختلف
لا ده هو تقريبا اما عنده حاجه هنجت او
حاجه لان اخونا خالد بيسال سؤال السيسي
كتير جدا جدا والافانتريك كتير جدا فاعتقد
ان انا هيحصل للاخر كده لو كان في سؤال
مختلف او نختم
ماشي
هل ممكن سبب قطع العلاقات مصر هو نشر
ونشرها
يعني تقريبا ابو عثمان محاوله نشرها
العقيده الفاسده الشيعيه انا بتحفظ ده
رايك انت انا انا الناس حره فيما يعترقوا
من مذاهب بس اشك في هذا لانه الوجود
الشيعي في مصر
والمحدود جدا جدا
ما اعتقدش يعني
انا هاخد من الاخر الاول هل ممكن
نبوس الاسئله في يوم ثاني اه طبعا اخونا
كريم يا ريت يعني بس ده معنا ايه يعني
اذا كان قصدك كده احنا بنعمل لايف كل
اسبوعين بكل سرور
انا استاذنكم احنا تقريبا وصلنا
لنهايه الساعتين انا عارف ان في اسئله
تانيه بتيجي بس معلش استاذنكم
ان احنا نكتفي بهذا القدر من الاسئله
وان شاء الله نستانفها في لقائنا المباشر
مره تانيه
اذا كان هذا النوع من المباشر انا عارف ان
انا طرحت السؤال بكده طريقه بس انا ما
بيجليش اجابات ممكن اعمل استفتاء بقى افضل
هنعمله كل اسبوعين ولا كل اسبوع انا شاكر
جدا جدا لكم بعتذر على الانقطاع بس جايز
الانقطاع ده جاي كده يعني يديكم فرصه
تاخدوا نفسكم
وانا بعتذر للناس اللي انا ما كانش في وقت
ان انا اجاوب اسئلتها اللي هي
اعاده مره اخرى انا شايف سؤال من الدكتور
ايمن ميدان ربنا يخليك ويحفظك دكتور ايمن
شكرا جزيلا صديق عزيز
وفي رد سريع كده حازم بيقول لي خليك كريم
وخليها لايف كل اسبوع بالعفو ده انتم اللي
كره ما بينك انت يعني تبذل تعطيني كل هذا
الجهد من وقتك يعني اشكرك اذا كان والله
يا استاذ سيد انا زعلان منك اول مره اشارك
وكتبت لك سؤال ولم تجب عليه
لا والله انا ايه سؤالك انا اسف يعني انا
ما شفتوش بس كل اسبوع افضل لو تقدر تكتبه
حالا انا قبل ما اقفل قول لي وانا اجاوبه
حاضر
ما جاني اشعار البث المباشر انا كتبته يوم
الاثنين وبكتبه على نعرف
اصل انا عاوز اقول لحضرتك على حاجه انا
لاحظتها انا في انتظار سؤالك يا اخونا سيد
ويندر عاوز اقول لحضرتك على حاجه انا على
القناه بقى لها اكثر من ست سنين او سبع
سنين لم يحدث مره واحده ان انا قلت اللي
هي العباره الشائعه استاذنكم اعملوا لايك
اعملوا شير ومش عارف افعله الجرس انا بخجل
ان القصه دي
دي انا بشوفها سخيفه يعني لكن هي لها
مزايا ثانيه ان من مزاياها ان انا ممكن
تنبه الناس من فضلك
لما تضغط على اشتراك فعل كمان بعض الخصائص
ان انت تكون فعال على لان كميونه القناه
انا بتخاطب فيه معكم باخد رايكم بطرح
الاسئله بنعلن فيه فاكون شاكر لو انت مهتم
ادخل على نعرف الام او نعرف اقتصاد
الاثنين هنتفاعل مع بعض اذا كان لك طلب
اذا كنا عملنا استفتاء فاسمع منكم يعني
عايزين نعمل جروب احنا عاملين جروب ما هو
يا احمد جمال جروب اكيد افضل من اللي هو
الواتساب والكلام ده كوميرت هو الجروب
وبالمناسبه الاسئله اللي بتجيلي انا بقرا
عدد كبير جدا منها والاسئله اللي بتيجي لي
على فيسبوك انا عارف ان بعض الرسائل
بتعديني سامحوني بس لو عدت مره واتنين ما
بتعديش كل مره يعني
معلش ننوه بس على جزئيه الجرس دي هي
الفكره بس عشان الناس المهتمه باللايف
عشان يجي لهم اشعار في كل لايك ايه الجرس
الجرس اللي هي ايه بالانجليزي
ان انت لو مشترك اما باللغه العربيه اللي
هي الاشعار
او تفعل خاصيه كل النوتيفيكيشن
فبالتالي ممكن تبقى مشترك وانت مش عامل
فلا يصلك من القناه الحلقات الجديده او
التنويه عليها او كذا يعني
اذا حبيتوا تعملوا كده اكون انا شاكر لكم
رد علي عاشق بني عثمان ما انا والله برد
انا هو في اسئله تاني انا ما خدتش بالي
منها ما جاني اشعار انا جبت عايزين نعمل
جروب انا اجابتك ان فيه
السلام عليكم اهل الاعتماد الاقتصادي
المتبادل بين الولايات المتحده والصيني
يمنع الصدام
طبعا عطل الصدام لانه كله منهم يحتاج
الاخر هل السعوديه مصر في طريقهما لتكوين
لتكون دول اقليمي لتلعب دور اقليمي مؤثر
ولا ولا مصير العرب ان يكونوا مستضعفين لا
يا اخي لا مش للدرجه دي لا السعوديه دوله
قويه
ومصر دوله واقفه على حيلها ومستقره في
مواجهه تحديات كثيره انا مش متشائم الى
هذا الحد ومارجوا ان انتم ما تفهموش كلامي
انه قوي كده لا انت بتسال تضخم هينحسر
خلال اسبوعين شهر بقول لك ما فيش مؤشرات
بتقول لي هل في دوله عربيه عندها مقاومات
الدوله العظمى بقول لك لا بس لما تسالني
احنا مستضعفين السعوديه مش مستضعفه
الامارات انا معجب جدا والله بدول يعني
انا اسف ما اقصدش يعني بس كان دول صغيره
محدوده مؤثره جدا على المستوى العربي وعلى
المستوى الدولي وكذا يعني
سؤال انا مش واخد بالي منه انا عارف ان
كانت اسئله تاني كتير بس انا قلت اقف عند
هل لديك تعليق عن كتاب مصر لروبرت لا ما
اعرفوش والله لو يعني انا ده احمد جمال ما
قالتش الكتاب معرفوش
كوثر مهتمه جدا مهتمه جدا بي كوثر مش عارف
بالم
شعارات اوكي لو ضغطت حضرتك على اول
نوتيفيكيشن او اشعارات كلها مش كده كل
الاشعارات شوفي حضرتك تابعي كده على مش
كده ولا على القناه
على الهوم بتاع القناه تحب تقول انت هو
انت سامعيني هتدوس بس فوق خالص كده
تمام بعد ما تدوس على علامه سبسكرايب
بيقول لك قول دوس عليها بس اذا كنت سمعته
كده ماندو يبقى تمام
لماذا الدول العالم الثلاث يكرهون
الولايات المتحده دول العالم الثالث لكن
الصين دوله شيوعيه بامتياز لا تحترم
مواطنيه او حقوق الانسان
حكايه الصين دوله شيوعيه ولا دوله اي حاجه
الناس بتقول انا مصالحي فين يعني العالم
العربي الصين مش هي اللي عملت اسرائيل
الصين مش هي اللي ضغطت على الدول العربيه
وهي اللي عملت الانقلابات في ايران وهي
الاشعلت الصرعات في الدول العربيه ومش هي
الا ناصرت اسرائيل في كل حروبها ومش هي
اللي فرضت شروق الصندوق
الولايات المتحده عندها تاريخ اسود مع
العالم العربي يعني يمكن لو الصين جت
وعملت نفس السياسه تكون نفس النتيجه بس ده
ما حصلش حتى الان يعني
السلام عليكم هل الاعتماد الاقتصادي
المتبادل الاجابته للذهب في السودان له
علاقه بعمله بريكس وهل هي سبب الصراع مش
عمله سبب الصناعه والذهب احد عوامل اللي
قوه شوكه حميدتي بحيث ان شجعته على
الاصطدام بس مش هو ده المشكله
الزياده السكانيه ستقضي على العالم تزاد
السكانيه بتتراجع يا صديقي احنا وصلنا
لحافه الثمانيه مليار لكن في تناقص في
النمو السكاني على المدى البعيد
انا اسف انا مضطر اقف انا بس سيد اه جابوا
جابوا خلاص
تدخل المصري ما زال خجول حتى الان حتى على
الصعيد الدبلوماسي هل هذه حكمه اما انا
سالت اهو
اذا كان السؤال صح انا انا مش انا مش شايف
وسط الاسئله لكن بيقول ليه ما تدخلتش
لتحرير الجنود الموقف المعلن واظن ان هو
الموقف الحقيقي انت تتدخل الموقف المعلم
بيقولوا ايه بيقولوا احنا قدرنا المساله
دي باكبر قدر ممكن من الهدوء يعني انا
عندي جنود هناك انا عارف انه
اصل هو تم حجز الجنود ليه كان في روايتين
ان ده متعمد وان ده خطا من الجنود المتعمد
يعني انا هحتجزهم رهائن
الشواهد كانت بتقول انه خطا اصلا من بعض
القاده التنفيذيين اللي احتجزوا الجنود
لانه ليس لمصلحه حماتي او مش لا يتخيل ان
يكون عنده مصلحه في انه يغضب دوله زي مصر
ويخليها تيجي تهجم عليه يعني بالطيران
وبالتالي كانوا بيرجحوا انه خطا ده واحد
اتنين بيقولوا طيب احنا عشان نحررهم ايه
البدائل نتفاوض معه نتفاوض مع اصدقاء
اخرين خصوصا احنا مش في اعداء مباشر حتى
الان يعني وبالتالي كانت وجهه نظرهم اذا
احنا تانينا نقدر نطلع جنودنا ونستعدهم
بهدوء بدون خسائر في الجنود المصريين بدون
خسائر في
السودانيين وحكايه الخسائر في الجنود
السودانيين ديت مساله حساسه المصريين لان
هم ما عندهمش استعداد ان يتم تصوير الجيش
المصري على انه بيقتل السودانيين دي مساله
تعقد علاقه هم حريصين جدا عليها والحقيقه
ان اللي فكروه فيه تم بالفعل السيناريو
الثاني كان ممكن يحصل بس كان يبقى الخيار
الاخير لانه دول مش جنود عمليه تحرير لو
افترضنا لا قدر الله ان هم اتخذ وراء وكذا
كانت تبقى عمليه اولا ده ما تمش على هذا
النحو
حمتي يوافق على ارسال القوات وبادر بان ده
كان امر غير مقصود وارسل القوات وبالتالي
كان الصبر والتاني كان فعلا ببني على منطق
واصفر عن عوده الناس بدون اي خسائر وده
كان شيء جيد لو كانوا بقى سمعوا كلامك يا
اخونا او تعجلوا في المساله كان بقى فيه
خسائر في الجنود المصريين وكانت عقلت قدره
مصر على انها تلعب وسيط مع قوات حميدتي
اللي بتنامل حتى هذه اللحظه ان الامور
تحل بالمفاوضات انا اسف جدا جدا ان انا
مضطر ان انا انهي هذا البث الجميل شكرا
لكل الاصدقاء شاكر جدا لكم وان شاء الله
نلتقي
في بثوث جمع بس يعني مباشره قريبا باذن
الله ونعمل استفتاء اذا كان كل اسبوعين او
كل اسبوع باذن الله اشكركم ربنا يسعد
مسائكم وكان اعتذاري عن الاخوه التي
الاخوه الذين لم اتمكن من اجابه اسئلتهم
استاذنكم نطرحها في البث المباشر القادم
الى اللقاء